hey is my Chang I'm Roy Wood jr. and
this is build yo squat yo or York
that's your Hall yo squat okay we're
picking the best basketball team with
athletes and other sports and we've got
$15 to do it right Roy thanks for
dressing up for this well you know I do
what I can
these are some of the best athletes in
their respective sports come none of
them basketball which one of these
athletes has the skills that transfer
over okay Tibet give it's real louis is
it wait what aren't you going like this
you're gonna go one we can pick from any
category it's just gotta equal okay so
your number one pick is Terrell Owens
football anybody on this board I believe
Terrell Owens best has the skills that
translate to basketball good height big
hands wide reach that's everybody on
this boy not everybody if he the Tioga
Deontay Wilder that's my starting center
one of these two but he's gonna know
he's gonna wear 50 pounds of cost you
everything
he was suiting his legs was tired so
what can he who is the question run yeah
can you just because he's wearing a
do-rag doesn't mean he can move
yesterday's well that's exactly what it
mean this guy is the prototypical diva
wide receiver you don't want this guy on
your team man
okay then you pick a center okay let's
start with a center I'm gonna go with
bubble Jackson you give me a cheap is a
dollar and also he's a dollar is a bonus
yes but he's the crime bill Jackson
Rainbow six two three yeah six to three
Center in every game small ball like the
Rockets now is a beaut I played Center
in every game I played
I'll give you Bo but not as the center
so what do you want Bo you want Bo to
play to 3 K power for the dollar now the
dollar down will pay up for both oh yeah
I'm actually supposed to put the ball on
the floor
we don't $15 yeah but I'm just throw on
the floor man let's make it rain
so Bo Jackson like that so we got our
three go Jacksons are three yeah what do
you want to go next
who's the tallest guy in this thing
Jimmy grant he actually played
basketball
he's got was a basketball star in a lot
of money
you get what you pay for man should
never let me pick either the two tall
black guys
I will go Tyson Fury there's the center
point Oh people off you're sort of boxed
out like this he's a better deal than
Jimmy Graham how this guy play
basketball like at a Division one level
what division $2 okay fine you want you
want you want to enforce her on the team
okay fine then you need a sinner then
this guy just beat this guy outfit he's
wearing a do-rag okay fine we'll go to
the doing okay fine Thank You Dante Wow
you got a sec we got three yeah point
got here's my pitch okay
Simone biles she'd take up on do flips
you know that stuff you sewing space
line stuff gymnasts are traditionally
short they're muscular
they got ups do did you see how high she
flipped you can't imagine her doing that
in game that's crazy
the best best in-game dunk about your
hip checkers she'll flip and fly right
out into the crowd
I think she's hotter HipChat anything
okay I like Simone but we got a pair
with somebody they can set the picks and
come off the ball who has the most money
just flip it around make one her two
soccer stars the one let them run point
Simone coming off the ball yeah doing
the flips yeah what is the forward in
soccer but a point guard coming down the
field seeing the vision seeing what's
going on reading what the defense is
doing and figuring out where to
distribute these to our master
distributes Alex Morgan over P no I
don't like any soccer players for
basketball just because I feel like they
don't they literally dribble yeah but
not only what the maneuver is called in
soccer is dribble it's like watching
people play that left hand so because
they never use their hands before a
clinics yeah
soccer players out I think so yeah okay
no okay let's play for Simone let's just
start right there come on pass the ball
to it my point is she can't flip and
have
we got a pass through the ball ball flip
five six seven eight nine dollars for
what two players the students of this
guy play play basketball collegiate
level is literally ridiculous do not
picture at all
he's a pro athlete and he played at a
high level that'll run before okay
thank you but we got how much we have
four dollars four dollars on a shooting
right yeah okay so Lamar or Russell
Wilson it goes with my is a bit taller
there you go
I like this boom that's a $15 and we
solved nothing that's right
he's running Chang I'm Roy with junior
we just built our squad with yo squad
our squad
he'll just squat in the comments below
and your squad will get trashed by our
squad get all of your election coverage
on The Daily Show Comedy Central
weeknights 11:00 10:00 central